[音楽]
[拍手]
今日私がお話したいのは
え答えは全て生徒の中にあるという考え方
を申し上げたい
え企業産業会の
え生産性理論の中で学習についての2つの
考え方が存在します1つ
は学習
は学習者の本能で
ありほっといても学び続けるものであるま
仮にここでは学習イコール本能説という風
に呼びましょうかもう1つの考え方
は人間はくと学習しないしって強制力とか
外部からは刺激でないと学習しないという
考え方2つこちらは学習イコール強制力説
とでも名付けましょうか私は高校時代大学
時代あまり熱心な学習者ではありません
でした試験がうまくいけばいいという考え
方があった時代が長いです大きな試験が
終わります
と
嫌な思い出を忘れ去ろうという力学が自分
の中で働いたことが多々ありましたそんな
自分ですが何のきっかけかいろんな
きっかけが積み重なりまして39歳の時に
学校を作ろうということになりました
いろんな不登校の子供たちの出会いがま
関東中心にありましてそれが後押しをして
くれましたあと結婚した相手が小学校の
先生だったということも大きな要素でした
まるで私はIT業界でしたんで関係のない
業界から学校を作るっていう風に思ったん
です本当に無活でした今だったらそんな
こと思いもしなかったと思いますそれだけ
私も若かったんだと思いますそれ
以来24年間3つの広域通信性高校を作っ
てきまし
たま中で私が作った思いは作る同機になっ
たのは学習イル本能説だったんですけど
やはり日本のえ歴とした通信性功を作る
とい2項目から3校目に関してはもう国の
基準が多々ありますのでそれに従わないと
いけないその考え方の背景にはやはり学び
て生徒はほっておくと学ばないんだと学べ
ないんだという考え方があったように思っ
て
私の中でも右に左と考えが揺れまし
たそんな時
に2人の生徒が私に背中を押してくれまし
て学習イコール本能説が正しいんだという
こと証明してくれました1人
は小学校時代振動と呼ばれてましてえ
ワームホールとかブラックホールなどを
解明してしたり竜巻の起こる現象を実験し
て実験結果をみんなの前で発表したりま
そんなこともできるえ生徒でしただ彼は
ただ学習障害の中でも読みと書きの中で
書きの障害がありましたんでえペンを使っ
て書くのができなかったんですで小学校
時代は
えITえワプロとかパソコンを教室に
持ち込むことを許されましたので比較的
スムーズに行ったんですけども中学校に
入りましたらそれはダメだと言われてです
ねそれから不登校になんだなってきて自己
肯定感が下がりえ中逆転でゲームに没入
するという風になってえきましたそれ以外
にも様々な精神障害が少し出てメンタル
不全ま決まったお決まりのパターンと言っ
てもいいかもしれませんまそんな生徒だっ
たんですですで私たちの学校に入りまして
え大方2年が過ぎようとした時にえ私が
少しま校長面談っていうことであのお話を
しようと思ったんですけどえすごい拒否
反応に会いまして先生が言おうとしてる
こと分かるよ
とそれからですね彼が本当に決を変えて
勉強って何のためにあるんですか試験って
何のためにあるんです
か先生が作った試験問題なぜ解かなきゃ
いけないんですかしかも制限時間があるの
はんですどうしてですかそこに競争の
ランク付けするっていうのはどんな意味が
あるんですか僕たちにとってはメリットは
そんなないと思いますと試験の評価標点に
ついても自分たちの意見は言えないんです
か反映されないんですか
ものすごい全身前例で訴てきましたそれ
だけ彼は小学校から中学校に上がる時の
ショックが大きかったんですね家の中の壁
も壊してましたしえ本当にあのま身体症状
も様々出ていましたまそんなれの訴から私
の中
でま私たちの学校は個別教育支援計画って
いうの特徴としてまして教育面生活面対人
関係面いろんな面から多食集の職員が個別
教育支援計画を立てるんですけども彼の
場合は私はあのたち職員にえ申したのは彼
の中に回不快というこう概念があるので彼
が快適と思う学習について後押しをして
いこうじゃないかということで会不会の会
に基づいて教育支援をしようというま後に
も先にも前例がないですねこんな支援計画
はでえまそこまで行った彼を本当に信じ
きろうと思いましたま親さんも説得しまし
さ半年ぐらい経ったら自分で生活サイドも
改めて変わっていったんですよね本当に
見事に変わってきましたえ死亡する大学も
あのちょっと1年浪人しましたけどもで
願った学校も大学も受かりました本当に
こう見る見るうちに変わりましたもう1人
はえ福岡出身なんですが東田直樹っていう
え賞で今世界に名を知られるえ作家なん
ですが彼がえ千葉の養護学校中学卒業して
え普通過の高校に進学したくてですね東京
千葉の高校を当たったんですけど全て受験
拒否に会いましたで周りもあって私たちの
学校にえ出したいと言ってきたんですねあ
随分迷いましたただ私は彼が小学校時代
からパソコンで書いた絵本エッセーを読ん
でましたしいろんなドキュメンタリー見て
ましたのでえなんとか受けれてみたいと
思ってえ職員を口説いてえ本当に発言が
困難な自衛症ですしもうパニックもかなり
起きてましたので
え他の学校がですねえ受験さえも認めない
とよく分かるんですけども私は何のため
学校作ったのかっていうそういう生徒の
ためにも学校は存在すべきだと思ったその
原点にを否定するようなことはできなかっ
たので迷いながらも受け入れましたただ
試験制限時間の中で試験を彼に課する
なんてことはできませんので時間はいくら
かけてもいいというような形のいわゆる
生果物学習ポートフォリオ学習などを
取り入れましてえ成績評価についても先生
たちと議論を重ねました無事3年で卒業し
ました卒業して何年か45年経ったらある
1年Amazonでええニュースで
飛び込んできたのが彼の書いた自衛症の僕
が飛び跳ねる理由っっていう本がですね
世界中で翻訳されましてイギリスアメリカ
ではAmazonで全ジャンルトップを数
週間数えたんですねまそれは私にとっては
本当に晴天の歴と言いましょうかあ生き
てる間にこんなことで起きるんだなって
いう風に正直思いました学校やってて
よかったなっていう思いましたあこんな
生徒がいるんだ自衛症でもICTの力通信
性の力でこうなるんだと自己工程が上がる
んだとやっぱり学習本能なんだなって本当
信じてよかったなって風に思わせてくれ
ましたまその2人のみならず通信性は大人
が望む学習をさ長期間に渡ってさせられた
生徒があまりに多いので2次障害3障害
学習勉強なんかしたくないって口では言っ
てるセットがあたいます
そんな環境ですのでま心の声がやっぱり
聞こえてくるんですね最後の学びの
チャンス僕たちに与えてほしいという心の
声が心の声が聞こえてくるんですね私たち
はあの教員と福祉系の支援員とえ心理士が
常駐した多食種連携チームっていう担任
チームを作るのがそれ以来私たちのえもに
ななってきましたまそういった生徒があの
私たちのやっぱり原点を絶えず思い
知らせてくれるっていう学校なのでえ
セーフティ最後のセーフティネットが通信
性だろうと思うんですけども本当に責任感
持ってえ取り組むしかないような状況
ですまこんな学校の中で考えることがあり
ますえ先生とは
文字通り先に生まれたと書きますけども先
に生まれただけで先生と言える時代はもう
過ぎ去ったじゃないかとこれからはIAI
も入ってきますまパソコンがはでき
インターネットができスマホができついに
AIが登場します定型的な学び正解は1つ
知識は必ずここに行きつくみたいなそう
いった学びはもうAIには叶いませ
ん人間に最後に残さされた可能性は自由
意思そが自分なりの興味関心だと思います
これだけはAIには勝ちますそれを開発し
絶えず刺激を与え共に走る高ランナーであ
るっていうのが学校の姿だと思います教員
は先生は先に行き続けていかないともう
無用の価値だというな聞き意識を今私たち
は持ち始めていますで大人の持ってる知識
経験が今子供たちの学びの環境には害を
与えてると言っても差し使えないと思い
ます改革イノベーションを妨げるのは自分
が大人が持ってる知識経験だと思います
子供たちがAIと初めとしてITを使うと
ですね新しい学びを実現してくれるんです
それを注視して一緒に走っていく支援と
伴奏していくのがこれからの教育者の役目
だと私は信じて疑いませ
ん答えは全て生徒の中にある学びは本能で
あるそれを開発していくのがま教育者始め
今日お集まりの皆様大人全般に共通する
問題意識ではなかろうかとえ信じています
ま賛同していただければ是非皆さんも教育
者です我がかもしれません地域の方もそう
かもしれません是非教育活動に加わって
いただきたい働き方改革では教員たちは
なかなか今経営しがちですブラックな職場
と言われますそうじゃありません目の前で
生子供たちが変わっていきますマイナス
から大きく羽ばたい
てため口も効いてきますし本当に見上げる
ような瀬がどんどん出てきますこんな夢な
ある仕事は他にないと思いますので是非何
らかの形で加わっていただいてできれば
この通信成功校も気に入っていただいて
愛していただいて是非仲間に加って
くださいありがとうございまし
た